glauben sie dass das die öffentlich
rechtlichen in not geraten oder ist
vielleicht doch noch irgendwo ein
bisserl einsparpotenzial ich glaube die
not kann nicht so groß sein wenn ich mir
die gehälter anschaue die
pensionsrückstellung oder auch mehr als
100 standorte für die und zdf und die
die ganzen programme also ich glaube
schon dass es da möglichkeiten gibt die
not und wenn man das wort gebrauchen
kann zu lindern gibt es eben doch noch
möglichkeiten ohne dass das programm
schlechter wird einzusparen
ich glaube es gibt schon möglichkeiten
wenn man hier lebt
die uns hätte er vom bundestag auftreten
sie sind meist zu dritt oder zu viert
und dann private kommen sind die er zu
zweit beim kamerateam und
pensionsrückstellung des im
entspannendes thema und wenn die masse
der chefs der ard anstalten mehr als die
bundeskanzlerin im jahren einkommen hat
dann gibt's da auch ein paar
fragestellungen recht glaubt die und zdf
sollten ein bisschen in sich gehen maß
und mitte halten sie bekommen gemeinsam
über acht milliarden vom gebührenzahler
und vielleicht auch mal überlegen ob es
in corona zeiten wirklich notwendig ist
jetzt in dieser situation nach karlsruhe
zu gehen und sage sozusagen
bundesverfassungs größe unser problem
wenn eine gebühr steigen soll für einen
rundfunk für den sehr viele deutsche
eigentlich gar nichts mehr zahlen wollen
dann ist das nicht empörend wenn jetzt
ein politiker diese erhöhung stoppt dann
ist seltsam wenn fast alle anderen
politiker diese erhöhung nicht mehr
hinterfragt haben fans für die erhöhung
dieser gebühr so was wie ein
automatismus gibt wenn ein nein dazu als
undemokratisch gilt kritik am
öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunk ist
gerechtfertigt vor allem wenn wir dafür
höhere gebühren zahlen sollen
diese kritik an der ard die gehört nicht
der afg sie gehört mit denen die lügen
presse brüllen sondern sie gehört denen
die wirklichen besseren rundfunk wollen
für ihre gebühren die gestoppte erhöhung
die ist so was wie ein aufruf an den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk der
aufruf besser zu werden für acht
milliarden
euro denn viele deutsche geraten in
dieser corona zeit wirklich in not ard
und zdf nicht